here it is this little building is a two
million dollar bathroom two million
dollars I had to check it out I was
expecting gold plating fixtures it's
just a toilet couple urinals two sinks
two million dollars to the people who
use this part know what taxpayers paid
for their bathroom what should something
like this cost
um a couple thousand seventy thousand
proximately hundred thousand maybe Oh me
they spent two million dollars for this
unbelievable Wow Wow you could buy a
nice house here for two very price yeah
you could buy a big house there you can
this nearby house was advertised for
much less
he has six bedrooms in the millions for
this this is ridiculous where is the
money go good question
everything cost more when government
builds it Washington DC's visitor center
was supposed to cost 265 million it
ended up costing 600 billion the
veterans affair medical center near
Denver was projected to cost 590 million
now they estimate 1.7 billion government
spends more because every decision is
tied up in endless rules minority
outreach wheelchair access zoning rules
and much more your department puts out
of statement the current estimate to
build a new bathroom is 3 million
dollars it is now approaching in some
cases going over 3 million Mitchel
silvers new york's parks commissioner
this is the most expensive market in the
world so 2 million was a good deal here
2 million was a good deal we build these
conference stages to last but you can
buy whole houses from in that
neighborhood for less than what you
spent on this bathroom I hear that point
often and if you look at the material
that we use compared to a home these are
very very durable material that's nice
but this bathroom is made of durable
materials - it's so beautiful that a
newspaper said it might be the fanciest
in New York yet it costs 150
as much why well it's in nearby Bryant
Park and Bryant Park is privately
managed Bryant Park built one with just
as many sinks and toilets for a fifth
the price Bryant Park did a renovation
when we build our conversations we do it
from the ground up but why why there
knock down your own one you just look
the same thing Commissioner silver says
this has to be especially sturdy because
we're to expect thousands of not
hundreds and thousands of visitors in
that facility over its lifecycle but
privately run Bryant Park gets more use
no comparison it's so busy people wait
in line to get in is another reason
government work costs more is the
government pays more we pay prevailing
wage so we availing lay prevailing wage
Union way this is a city that does
believe strong in labor and they want to
make sure that people get paid a
prevailing wage prevailing wage turns
out the mean union wages sometimes more
than a hundred dollars an hour that
makes everything cost more and when we
watched the workers didn't seem to work
very hard the final reason this cost so
much is that it took years to build it
it took less time to build the Empire
State Building we've now saved five
months out of what used to be four years
five years per project we're now doing
them three years in some cases under so
we've shaved five years ago so instead
of five years it's four and a half years
that's still terribly worth three years
and now we just finished one of our
projects in under three years why does
it make you three years to build a
bathroom we have a process that includes
design procurement and construction so
does the private sector ours because of
the public project we believe very
strongly and engaging the public
engaging the public means things like
the city planning departments uniform
land-use review procedure try doing
something quickly while following these
rules clearly private sector does not
have to go through that same process
this is a good thing the public process
all these need oh yes it's a good thing
ridiculous amount of money one little
building two million dollars that's
government at
work
you